STEVE: WE ARE BACK WITH A FOX
BUSINESS ALERT ON THIS FRIDAY
MORNING, STOCK FUTURES RIGHT NOW
RALLYING LOOKING TO GAIN BACK
SOME OF YESTERDAY’S BIG LOSSES,
BRIAN.
BRIAN:  I’M SEASICK, THE DOW
PLUNGING MORE THAN 1,800 POINTS
THE WORST DAY SINCE MID MARCH,
WE KEEP SETTING RECORDS BOTH
WAYS THE NASDAC LOSING 527
POINTS AND S&P DROPPING 188
POINTS AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: THE LOSSES CAME AS
CORONAVIRUS CASES SPIKE IN
SOME PARTS OF OUR COUNTRY AND
INVESTORS SEE A RESURGENCE OF
THE INFLECTIONS.
STEVE: LET’S BRING IN LARRY
KUDLOW DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
ECONOMIC COUNCIL HE JOINS US
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
SO LARRY SOME PEOPLE SAID THAT
THE BIG SELL-OFF YESTERDAY WAS
BECAUSE THERE’S A SPIKE IN CASES
IN A NUMBER OF STATES MAYBE
THERE’S GOING TO BE A SECOND
WAVE.
WAS IT THAT OR  WAS IT THE FACT
THAT WE’VE HAD SUCH A RUN-UP IN
THE STOCK MARKET.
PEOPLE THOUGHT DO YOU KNOW WHAT
THIS MIGHT BE A GOOD TIME TO
TAKE SOME PROFIT.
>> IT’S PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT
OF BOTH THOSE ARE BOTH GOOD
POINTS.
I’M NOT THE HEALTH EXPERT BUT
I’M THE SO-CALLED SPIKE.
I SPOKE TO OUR HEALTH EXPERTS AT
SOME LENGTH LAST EVENING.
THEY’RE SAYING THERE IS NO
SECOND SPIKE.
LET ME REPEAT THAT.
THERE IS NO SECOND SPIKE AND
SECRETARY MNUCHIN SAID YESTERDAY
IN TESTIMONY AND I TOTALLY AGREE
WE ARE NOT GOING TO SHUT DOWN
THE ECONOMY.
WHAT YOU DO HAVE IS CERTAIN
SPOTS ARE SEEING A LITTLE BIT OF
A JUMP UP SOME SMALL
METROPOLITAN AREAS ARE SEEING IT
, THE CDC AND THE HEALTH
PEOPLE ARE ALL OVER IT AND
THEY’VE SENT TASK FORCES OUT TO
DEAL WITH IT.
NOW DAYS WE HAVE MUCH BETTER
EQUIPMENT, MUCH MORE EXPERIENCE,
MUCH MORE TESTING I MEAN THE
TESTING ITSELF HAS JUMPED UP
, SO YOU’RE GOING TO GET A
LITTLE MORE POSITIVE FROM THAT
BUT IF YOU LOOK NATIONALLY THE
IMPORTANT POINT IS THE RATE
OF INCREASE OF NEW CASES IS
BETWEEN 0-1% ITS REALLY FLATTEN
ED OUT AND WITH RESPECT
TO FATALITIES IT’S THE SAME IT’S
ACTUALLY LOWER THAN THAT IT’S
LIKE 0 TO HALF A PERCENT, SO IF
I CAN CALM FEARS AGAIN, I’M NOT
THE HEALTH EXPERT.
AMBASSADOR BIRX MAY BE ASKED
ABOUT IT LATER TODAY BUT
NONETHELESS THERE IS NO
EMERGENCY, THERE IS NO SECOND
WAVE.
I DON’T KNOW WHERE THAT GOT
STARTED ON WALL STREET.
BRIAN:  I TELL YOU I LOVE THE
FACT THAT SEC OF TREASURY
MNUCHIN SAYS NOT ANOTHER
SHUTDOWN REGARDLESS MEANWHILE
LET’S TALK ABOUT YOU HAVE MONEY
LEFT FROM THE  PPP PROGRAM SO
THERE’S A LOT OF CONCERN THAT
THE TIME IS UP AND THEY’RE GOING
TO TURN INTO A LOAN INSTEAD OF A
GRANT.
SO WHAT ARE THE CHANGES TO THE P
PP PROGRAM AND TAX CREDITS
THAT YOU COULD TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ABOUT?
>> WELL TWO CHANGES FROM THE
LEGISLATION THE PRESIDENT
SIGNED LAST FRIDAY AND BY THE
WAY LET’S NOT FORGET LAST
FRIDAY WE HAD AN INCREDIBLE
INCREASE OF 3 MILLION JOBS PLUS
THE LOWER UNEMPLOYMENT RATE,
WHICH SHOWS THAT THE REOPENING
IS MOVING INTO ECONOMIC REBOUND.
NOW HAVING SAID THAT, THERE’S
ABOUT I DON’T KNOW, 100 BILLION
PLUS LEFT IN THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
THEY’VE DONE A REMARKABLE JOB
GETTING IT OUT IN FACT
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OFFICE CIT
ED FOR EFFICIENCY IN GETTING
THESE THINGS OUT.
THERE IS ABOUT 100 BILLION LEFT.
I THINK THEY EXTENDED IT THE
CONGRESSIONAL LEGISLATION
EXTENDED IT I BELIEVE FROM EIGHT
WEEKS TO 24 WEEKS, AND WITH
RESPECT TO ALLOCATION OF THE
LOANS, WHICH PROBABLY WILL
BE FORGIVEN, YOU’VE GOT 60% NOW,
ALLOCATED TO PAYROLLS, SO 40%
CAN GO TO OTHER EXPENSES, WHICH
ARE IMPORTANT.
I THINK IT WAS A CONSTRUCTIVE
CHANGE THAT THE PRESIDENT DID
FAVOR.
AINSLEY: SO LARRY, YOU MENTIONED
THE INCREASE OF 3 MILLION JOBS
WITH THE LAST JOBLESS CLAIMS
REPORT.
WHEN DO YOU EXPECT THAT WE WILL
REBOUND?
WILL THAT BE BEFORE THE ELECTION
, REBOUND TO WHERE
WE WERE BEFORE CORONA?
>> WELL LOOK THERE’S SO MANY
GREEN SHOOTS POPPING UP IN TERMS
OF EARLY RECOVERY THAT’S WHAT’S
GIVEN US A MUCH MORE OPTIMISTIC
FEELING.
I MEAN, NOT ALL IS WELL YET.
I GET THAT.
THERE’S STILL A LOT OF
HEARTBREAK.
YOU’VE STILL GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
UNEMPLOYED SO THERE’S A LOT OF
HEARTBURN ON THAT AND THAT’S
GOING TO BE A PROBLEM, BUT, BUT,
BUT, BUT, LET ME SAY WHETHER
IT’S THE APPLE ABILITY INDEX
WHICH SHOWS MORE PEOPLE
TRAVELING BY CAR, WHETHER IT’S
NEW BUSINESS APPLICATIONS WHICH
ARE SOARING, BUSINESSES ARE OPEN
, AUTOMOBILE DEMAND IS
STRONG, HOUSING DEMAND IS OFF
THE CHARTS RIGHT NOW BACK TO PRE
-PANDEMIC LEVELS.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THESE
GREEN SHOOTS THAT SUGGEST NUMBER
ONE, WE ARE REOPENING, NUMBER
TWO, THE PAYROLL PROTECTION
PROGRAM DID WORK, SO WHAT YOU
GOT INSTEAD OF 18 MILLION PEOPLE
, ON TEMPORARY LAYOFFS IT
DROPPED TO 15 MILLION PEOPLE,
3 MILLION PEOPLE WENT BACK TO
WORK.
LOOKING AT THIS NOW, I THINK
VIRTUALLY, 100% OR  90 PERCENT
OF SMALL BUSINESSES WILL REOPEN
IN THE NEXT MONTH.
THE NUMBER IS 80% ACCORDING TO
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
THAT HASN’T BEEN SCORED YET, SO
WHEN WE GET THE JUNE FIGURES IN
JULY, I’M LOOKING FOR ANOTHER
DECLINE IN UNEMPLOYMENT AND
ANOTHER BIG INCREASE IN
EMPLOYMENT AND I SEE NO REASON
WHY THIS CANNOT, YOU KNOW,
JOURNAL ITSELF THROUGH.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR 20% ECONOMIC
GROWTH IN THE SECOND HALF OF THE
YEAR.
WE REFERENCED THE CONGRESSIONAL
BUDGET OFFICE THERE TOO.
THEY ARE SEEING SIMILAR NUMBERS,
AND A VERY STRONG 2021, AND THE
PRESIDENT REBUILT THIS
ECONOMY ON LOWER TAXES AND
DEREGULATION ONCE.
THOSE THINGS ARE STILL GOING TO
BE IN PLACE.
HE CAN REBUILD IT AGAIN.
WE WILL PROBABLY HAVE ECONOMIC
GROWTH ORIENTED LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE NEXT MONTH WHEN WE COME
AROUND TO FORMAL
NEGOTIATIONS SO I SEE THE GLASS
IS WAY HALF FULL AND I THINK
AMERICA IS GOING TO TAKE OFF
AGAIN LIKE A ROCKET, THIS
HURRICANE, THIS BAD
SNOWSTORM, THIS TERRIBLE
PANDEMIC VIRUS IS GOING TO GO
AWAY, AND WE WILL BE OKAY, I
MEAN, PEOPLE HAVE TO KEEP THEIR
CHINS UP I THINK.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT, WITH AN
OPTIMISTIC VIEW FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, LARRY KUDLOW,
LARRY THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A